my talk of the table is about the
breakout band the black pumas who are
performing this sunday at the grammy
awards
in our road to the grammy series we're
counting down to music's biggest night
the recording academy's 63rd annual
grammy awards
black pumas are nominated for three
awards best american roots performance
record of the year and album of the year
we caught up with former street busker
eric burton and grammy-winning guitarist
adrian quesada
to talk about their unlikely but turns
out
perfect pairing
the opening guitar riff is the first
thing that grabs you
i woke then
the black pumas song colors breaks out
into a soul-funk anthem
for the age
colors put the pumas on the map but even
they were surprised it scored a grammy
nomination
for record of the year
wow that's crazy man gotta pinch myself
just six years ago eric burton was
busking for money
singing that same song on the santa
monica pier
this has been an incredible journey you
know i knew that
it was going to be something special i
really did we're just in another
stratosphere of
it beyond anything i would have imagined
adrian quesada the band's 43 year old
guitarist
and producer and burton the 30 year old
lead singer
formed the band four years ago in austin
texas
after a mutual friend connected them
you met basically over the phone right i
only can imagine like what my girlfriend
was thinking at the time
in the back room listening to me sing to
another man over the phone
um but that's pretty much how we came
together adrian what did you think
when you heard eric singing on the phone
i was like this is it this is
this is the guy i need to get into the
studio with
[Music]
their first session burton and quesada
recorded black moon rising
when would you say you knew you had
something
to be honest i i knew i had something
with adrian
the first time we we got into the
to studio so they put a band together
and booked the black pumas into weekly
gigs
at sea boys heart and soul in downtown
austin
we're like rocking out with adrian
coming up here like maybe like
like a few songs in was like know you
better or something adrian would rock
out and i do like my little
pin drop you know bust down and get
up again
the buzz built immediately man i
remember meeting like jeezy top over
there like ordering a drink
before long owner steve wertheimer says
the lines stretched for blocks it was
all the way down
to where the magnolia sounded
the black pumas were an overnight
sensation
but their sudden success was actually
built on years of hard work
quesada had been a mainstay in the
austin music scene
playing for 13 years with a latin fusion
collective called
grupo phantasma learned everything i
know
about being in a band from from being
with those guys you know
grupo fantasma won a grammy in 2011 for
best latin rock album
and prince even asked them to be his
backing band
for a string of gigs what was it like to
play with prince
we were like a good high school
basketball team and playing with prince
was like
get on a flight and you're in game seven
of the nba finals the next day
he just had that kind of faith in us and
it was just incredible i just can't even
believe that it happened you know
[Music]
burton was living in south central l.a
when he started busking on the santa
monica pier
i played for myself i just bought a
permit as a busker you would go down to
the pier at the
very beginning of the day to put your
name in a fish bowl of names
and whoever got chosen for the 14 spots
i believe it is
got to work that day
you took a couple of buses and a couple
of trains to get there right
most definitely three buses and a couple
of trains
take me hours to get there but it's made
me who i am for
[Music]
thank sure this is my doctor
burton chased his musical dreams to
austin
and bust there too on the corner of
sixth
and congress i actually have the amp
that i had when i was busting something
yeah
man since cube double a battery powered
had a microphone set up that i'd i'd
come out here on a skateboard with like
you know the tip jaw yeah
[Music]
when burton and quesada set up for old
time's sake last month
they quickly drew a crowd fans followed
the music
from blocks away
the black pumas are an austin
institution now
thank you guys man hello thank you very
much
their debut album also up for a grammy
for album of the year when you look at
the first record now
what do you hear the sound of that album
to me
if it were a visual you'd see two hands
shaking
but it's just the beginning burton says
of a beautiful
friendship i think it's already sounding
like we we know each other a little bit
more and so
for me it feels like there's no place we
can go but uh
[Music]
it's an amazing story with these two
guys when you think about how far they
come so fast
although they've been working for years
well you know overnight sensation yeah
it's a long night yes
exactly and you know and the other thing
is when we went when our when our my
producing team
led by rebecca castaneda went around
trying to get pictures of them in old
videos people were volunteering stuff
all over the place and saying we love
these guys we're so excited
by what's happening to them so there's a
lot of folks behind them rooting for
them you know what gets me about your
pieces
is even if i'm not into the group by the
time the piece is over i'm thinking now
i want to get their music
and only it has only not happened one
time with a story
we'll talk about who that was later the
story was good but the music still
wasn't for me i'm not saying anything
about that
there's always what i like is i didn't
know with busking
you had to have a permit i thought
people just laid down their guitar case
and they just went
and played i didn't know there was a
system to it and then you had to
because otherwise you'd have you'd have
you'd have 50 people on the pier you
know all plain music
i hadn't thought of it that way six
years ago that song which is up for
grammy for record of the year yeah
played on a pier i know for
demonstrations i'm getting the black
pumas music i like their stories i like
them
great albums to see more of the black
pumas busking in austin head to our cbs
this morning facebook
twitter or instagram accounts and
tomorrow on cbs this morning
pop star what's her name tony hualipa
yes
yeah for six grammys you can watch black
pumas
and perform at the 63rd annual
grammy awards this sunday 8 eastern 5
pacific
right here on cb and